m
durant les vacances scolaires le jardin
botanique de la réunion met en place
différents ateliers à destination des
enfants
une belle expérience à vivre au coeur
des collections végétales de ce jardin
emblématique alors au niveau de mascarin
nous avons
trois types d'actions pendant les
vacances une action tournée vers les
ateliers pour des enfants donc avec des
ateliers d'arts plastiques qui est
organisé par christelle giro qui est
vitrailliste de métier qui a travaillé
pendant dix ans à l'unesco
des ateliers de photo avec thomas girod
qui est un photographe professionnel
nous avons également des animations à
travers des ateliers pour la découverte
des sols puisque cette année c'est
l'année des sols donc on a on amène par
les médiateurs du jardin aux enfants à
découvrir les espèces indigènes et le
monde de souterrains l'atelier arts
plastiques et orchestré par christelle
giro cette passionnée souhaite partager
son talent en particulier avec les
enfants elle propose aux jeunes des
stages de quatre jours qui leur
permettent de découvrir les différentes
techniques d'arts plastiques tout en
s'imprégnant de l'environnement végétal
du jardin botanique
l'outil on peut toujours le sens inverse
différemment avec une petite pointe avec
l'eau bout avec la largeur
il y a le geste aussi le dessin c'est
plutôt la main et le poignet mais qui
vous avait le geste si c'est tout le
bras alors les ateliers pendant les
vacances ce sont des ateliers qui
s'appuie toujours sur les collections du
jardin botanique et les enfants donc
choisissons un thème s'inscrivent à
l'atelier où on développe un thème et ce
thème commence toujours par une matinée
d'observation voilà on observe des
végétaux des fleurs des écorces et puis
tout au long des quatre jours on passe
par différentes techniques pour exprimer
le prochain le projet de chaque enfant
dire que chacun va avoir une idée de ce
qu'il a envie de réaliser moi je suis là
pour l'aider à aller le plus loin
possible dans son projet des artistes en
herbe enchantés de pouvoir développer
leur créativité
on va essayer de reproduire un paysage
où va dire mais de la manière qu'on veut
enfin on peut jouer sur les proportions
et les les ombres ouais c'est
constructif pour c'est ça fait
travailler la créativité et
l'observation l'atelier photographie a
pour but de faire découvrir aux enfants
les bases de la photo numérique
au travers d'exercices ludiques ce stage
permet aux petits de développer leur
créativité mais aussi de stimuler leur
imaginaire par le récit d'histoires en
faute au long de ces quatre jours à
apprendre à bien cadrer un peu de
technique c'est à dire comment
fonctionne l'appareil photo et donc ils
peuvent à la fin savoir faire des photos
en en fonctions manuelles c'est à dire
connaître le réglage de la vitesse de
l'obturateur l'ouverture du diaphragme
donc aulas utilisons la connaissance
technique et aussi la composition aussi
le but c'est pour moi ma philosophie
c'est en apprend
on apprend en s'amusant on en prend
mieux en s'amusant
donc on va faire des petits jeux mais
toujours avec un petit avec un petit
toujours un but technique et ludique
le jardin botanique de la réunion est un
lieu idéal pour retranscrire selon la
vue de chacun toute la beauté de la
nature il est super parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de choses à apprendre en photo
et c'est là la vue et elle est parfaite
et j'adore cet endroit
bay a beaucoup de plantes il ya ya ya
des animaux aussi surtout des poissons
des plantes d'eau et voilà